signs are emerging that india's
coronavirus spike
may be easing the number of daily new
cases has been declining
over the last few days but the crisis is
far from over
the number of new infections still
dwarfs that of other countries
the health ministry says around 280 000
cases and more than
4 000 deaths have been officially
recorded
in the last 24 hours and the real figure
is thought to be much higher the
international community has been
delivering aid to india and dw's delhi
bureau chief amrita chima filed
this report on equipment sent by germany
dutch down in delhi on a hot sultry
evening
this military transport plane is
bringing a precious cargo to a country
struggling to cope with a deadly second
wave of the coronavirus
it is a medical oxygen generation plant
sent by germany being unloaded with care
it's part of an international aid effort
to bring relief
the city of delhi has gone through a
harrowing time
people have seen their loved ones
literally gasping for breath as oxygen
supplies
ran out any attempt to boost
oxygen supplies here is hugely welcomed
by nightfall the plant is taken to a
provisional field hospital
set up not far from the airport
13 members of the german bundeswehr
medical corps
came with this oxygen generation plant
to india
bit by bit the machinery is assembled
german precision meets indian ingenuity
within a few short days the generator is
ready for use
its capacity is large for a city which
has faced
a desperate oxygen emergency i think
it's important to help the indian people
in general the supply system is able to
provide 400 000 liters per day and it
takes the surrounding air and filters
the oxygen out
and this oxygen can be filled up into
normal oxygen cylinders
starting from 5 up to 50 liters indian
staff are receiving technical training
on how to operate the system
once the german team leaves as of today
scientists from the defense research
development organization
are now fully responsible for running
the plant
this sudden sandstorm was not planned
but everyone here is aware of the
importance of this project
definitely oxen was the you know were
required like anything in india in this
particular pandemic
and so that we are thankful to the
german government that they have
established the plan they have given
this plant to us and we are successfully
utilizing their
uh this particular german plant to
generate oxygen and to supply to the
various pandemic you know patients
the oxygen is pumped into cylinders
sealed and tested
and then sent to wards in the field
hospital where some 1 000 covet patients
are being treated 10 000 liters can be
filled
in less than half an hour time is of the
essence
as the german team prepared to leave
india
was its mission accomplished it's
absolutely mission accomplished and it
was a great honor to be here to help the
people here in india
with just providing oxygen due to the
fact that from our perspective every
little counts here
and those who faced india's
heartbreaking oxygen shortage can only
agree
they know every breath counts
you